okay you were talking about the old
school development inside the egg
right
what's uh what's what's better than that
what's what so then the next generation
of vaccines which arose in the 50s were
what we call replication competent where
the virus
you're taking it's actually reproducing
in you
yeah that sounds safe
and
it can be somewhat problematic yes as
you might imagine because you know once
you put that virus in you you have no
more control right it's not like you
have a kill switch in it which
actually would be a great idea to put in
like
like nano nano bots what composites no
you could just put something in there if
you added a drug you would shut it off
right
and people are thinking about that
because now we're engineering viruses to
treat
cancers and other diseases and we may
want to put kill switches in them just
to make sure they don't run away oh
interesting so you can like deploy a
drug that binds to the
this this virus that would shut it off
in the body something like that
something like that yeah that would be
the idea you'd have to engineer it in
any way these were the first one was
yellow fever vaccine
that was made because that was a big
problem and this virus and the way you
do this
back in the old day was empirical
so max tyler who did the yellow fever
vaccine he took the virus which is a
human
virus right
and he infected
i think he used chick embryos
and he went from one embryo to another
and just kept passing it did that
hundreds of times
and every 10 passages he would take the
virus and put it in a
a mouse or a monkey whatever his model
was and then eventually he got a virus
that didn't cause any disease
after 200 and some passages and then
that was tested in people
and it became the yellow fever vaccine
that we used today
he selected for mutations that
made the virus not
cause disease but still
make an immune response wow so those are
called replication competent we now have
the polio vaccine which was developed in
the 50s after the yellow fever then we
had measles mumps rubella those are all
replication competent vaccines
and you mentioned is that's that's a
good idea
they are all
safe vaccines the only one
that has had an issue is the polio
replication competent vaccine what's
called sabin vaccine or
oral polio virus vaccine
because
you take it orally it's a wonderful
because you don't have to inject it this
is the perfect delivery
you know either intranasal for a
respiratory virus or orally for polio
goes into your intestines it reproduces
and it gives you wonderful protection
against polio
however you do
shed virus out
and
that virus is no longer a vaccine it's
reverted genetically in your intestine
so you can infect others with pollution
take that virus and put it into an
animal and give it polio and in fact
the parents of some kids
in the 60s and 70s who were immunized
got got polio from the vaccine the rate
was about one and one and a half million
cases of polio so it's called
vaccine-associated polio and i always
argue that
we may not have picked the right vaccine
there was a big
fight in the
u.s and other countries between the
inactivated polio and the and the
infectious polio vaccines which ones we
should be using because we found out
that the infectious vaccine actually
caused polio and eight to ten kids a
year in the u.s alone got polio from the
vaccine which looking back is really
not acceptable in my view although the
public health community said it was to
get rid of polio so now we are
we're close to eradicating polio
globally
but this vaccine derived polio is a
problem so now we have to go back to the
an activated vaccine which is tough
because it's injected
you